[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24
desde hoy la Unión Europea restringió
todas las importaciones de petróleo ruso
transportadas por barco al bloque
comunitario además también prohibió
comprar barriles de crudo ruso que estén
por encima de los 60 dólares tampoco se
podrá transportar ni asegurar el
petróleo que supere ese precio y que
Moscú venda a terceros países el kremlin
respondió que no acepta estas medidas
casi 37 millones de menores de edad se
han tenido que desplazar a causa de la
crisis climática y de los conflictos que
hay en el mundo según lo reveló unicef
por este motivo el organismo aumentará
la petición de financiamiento y sube 900
millones de dólares en su financiación
con respecto al 2022 tendremos análisis
de este tema en unos minutos
y Croacia avanzó a los cuartos de final
y lo logró desde el punto penal el
partido contra Japón terminó en un
apretado uno a uno y se tuvo que ir a
tiempo de alargue mientras que Brasil
está jugando contra Corea Y a esta hora
vence por goleada ampliamos desde dos a
la capital de Qatar
Muy buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora
este lunes entraron en vigor las
limitaciones con las que la Unión
Europea espera reducir las ganancias
económicas de Rusia por cuenta de la
venta de petróleo por un lado el bloque
comunitario prohibió todas las
importaciones de crudo ruso por vía
marítima y también la Unión Europea el
g7 y Australia comenzaron a aplicar el
límite de precio al barril de petróleo
de Rusia para no comprarlo por encima de
los 60 dólares Rusia ha dicho que no
aceptará la medida Incluso si tiene que
cortar su producción algunos abogan por
un límite mucho más estricto como lo
pide por ejemplo el presidente ucraniano
bolo dimer selenski les contamos más en
el siguiente reporte
limitar los ingresos petroleros rusos
sin afectar al suministro mundial Ese es
el objetivo de la limitación del
petróleo ruso que impedirá que los
clientes paguen más de 60 dólares por
barril por el suministro de crudo en
buques cisterna esto se produce después
de que la Unión Europea aceptara las
sanciones pero fue necesario convencer a
Polonia que abogaba por un tope de 30
dólares el precio de Mercado del barril
de crudo ruso es actualmente solo unos 5
dólares superior al límite lo que llevó
al presidente ucraniano golodimir
zelenskia calificar las sanciones de
poco serias
desgraciadamente la discusión sobre los
precios máximos sobre la limitación del
precio de exportación del petróleo ruso
ha terminado sin una decisión seria Por
qué no se puede considerar una decisión
seria fijar tal límite para los precios
rusos que es bastante cómodo para el
presupuesto de un estado terrorista
significa que solo se permitirá el
transporte de petróleo ruso comprado a
60 dólares o menos de barril mediante
petroleros del g7 y la Unión Europea
compañías de y entidades de crédito esto
dificulta Moscú eludir las sanciones ya
que el 90% de las principales compañías
navieras y de seguros del mundo tiene su
sede en el g7 se produce el mismo día en
el que entra en vigor la prohibición en
toda la Unión Europea de importar crudo
ruso por mar el objetivo de estas
medidas golpear a la economía rusa donde
más le duele
antes de la invasión rusa a Ucrania la
Unión Europea obtenía aproximadamente
una cuarta parte de todo su petróleo de
Rusia por lo que eliminar estas
importaciones es un gran paso para
Europa
se espera que estas nuevas sanciones
tengan un efecto en el esfuerzo bélico y
el presupuesto militar ruso desde el
inicio del conflicto en Ucrania el
pasado mes de febrero se calcula que
Rusia ha ganado unos 67 mil millones de
euros con sus ventas de petróleo ruso a
la Unión Europea
Fuentes oficiales ucranianas afirmaron
que las tropas rusas atacaron diferentes
blancos en la ciudad de odesa también en
la región de saporilla y en las afueras
de la ciudad de nikolife esto a pesar de
que las fuerzas aéreas ucranianas
sostienen que derribaron 60 de los más
de 70 misiles lanzados en la jornada de
hoy por su parte la policía de la
República de moldavia encontró
fragmentos de un misil que supuestamente
cayó en una región del norte de ese país
muy cerca de la frontera con Ucrania
Rusia dice que Ucrania atacó dos
aeródromos en el territorio de la
federación en las regiones de
riazán y de zaratuve los bombardeos en
la región de kievejan Hasta el momento
el 40% de la región sin electricidad
según reporta el gobernador de ese
oblatz ucraniano
y los ataques en esta región de Ucrania
los vivió de cerca al alto comisionado
de la ONU para los Derechos Humanos
volker turk el adelanta una visita
oficial a la capital de ese país la
ciudad de kiev y Desde allí condenó los
ataques contra la infraestructura civil
de voz del wave hubo una ola de ataques
con misiles contra Ucrania algunos de
los cuales terminaron en las
proximidades de kiev se puede imaginar
lo que esto significa para la población
se ha convertido casi en una nueva
normalidad pero tiene un gran impacto en
los civiles y esto tiene que terminar
vamos a cambiar de tema casi 37 millones
de menores de edad han tenido que
desplazarse a causa de la crisis
climática y también de los conflictos
que hay alrededor del mundo la cifra la
dio a conocer unicef como parte de su
informe de acción humanitaria para la
infancia este nivel de afectación a los
menores de edad no se veía desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial según este
organismo también estimó que 16,5
millones de menores de edad y
adolescentes en América Latina y el
Caribe necesitan ayuda humanitaria para
el próximo año para entender esta
dimensión de estas cifras conectamos con
miquel de messina él es asesor Regional
de emergencias para América Latina y el
Caribe de la organización unicef que nos
acompaña a esta hora desde la ciudad de
Panamá Señor messina gracias por estar
con nosotros y ya lo estábamos diciendo
unicef habla de varias causas del
desplazamiento como las sequías las
inundaciones los conflictos armados las
migraciones y bueno también la pandemia
del Coby 19 como todo esto está
impactando a la niñez en el mundo cómo
se van a desarrollar estas generaciones
muy buenas Gracias por tenerme Santiago
un gusto estar con ustedes Así es Hoy es
un día importante es el día en que vamos
a comunicar con todos ustedes también
con los donantes y el sector privado y
otros para tener la necesidad
humanitarias increíbles que tenemos
alrededor del mundo verdad este este año
para el 2023 prevemos un número de niños
afectados de por crisis humanitarias Más
alto que nunca antes
registrados muchos de estos Como estabas
comentando son migrantes mujeres niños y
familias que se mueven de los lugares
de origen para buscar una vida mejor
como decías muy bien
entre las razones más importantes de
este movimiento al conflictos hay
violencia en la en América Latina el
tema de la violencia agudo violencia
urbana violencia en comunidades es un
factor importante para que la familia
decidan entender viajes muy peligrosos y
hay situaciones socioeconómicas muy
complejas en parte de vida al todavía a
la al covid a los efectos de covid que
han dejado una crisis económica muy
importante en muchos países de la región
claro y que ahora Estamos viendo
repuntes de algunos casos de covid en
algunos países de la región señor
messina unicef pidió
10.300 millones de dólares Para apoyar a
los 110 millones de menores de edad que
se están viendo afectados por todas
estas causas que usted estaba
mencionando esto es 900 millones más que
lo que solicitaron para el año 2022 se
alcanzó la meta de este año qué tan
posible es lograr esa financiación a
nivel internacional para el 2023
es muy complejo realmente no nosotros
cuando planificamos planificamos en base
a las necesidades entonces miramos a
todos los niños de los países afectados
por por la crisis y en muchos casos no
conseguimos llegar al monto deseado
Entonces nos encontramos realmente a
tener que priorizar y dejar algunos
niños y mujeres y sus familias
desatendido lo cual es una gran pena
claramente sí son niños estas familias
serían perjudicadas en su lucha y
voluntad para para alcanzar un futuro
mejor muchos de estos niños por la falta
de dinero no pueden no tienen beneficios
de acceso a servicios de salud como
vacunación algunos servicios que les
habla pueden salvar su vida a su
educación
a la identidad
la documentación entonces este año
También tenemos un problema de parte de
la crisis económica en los países
donantes verdad que se encuentran con
millones de dólares y esperamos
poder alcanzar los resultados señor
miquel mesina muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en France 24 habernos
puesto en contexto sobre esta situación
de la infancia alrededor del mundo
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros
muchas gracias a ustedes por acá
cambiamos nuevamente de tema Hablamos
ahora del presidente de Sudáfrica civil
rama fosa fue respaldado por su partido
en medio de ese escándalo de corrupción
que está enfrentando en este momento el
colectivo Congreso Nacional africano por
sus siglas en inglés dijo que votará en
contra de cualquier intento del
parlamento sudafricano para hacerle un
juicio político esto luego de que un
informe de el panel de expertos lo
señalará de Mala conducta y también de
violar la Constitución por supuestamente
esconder una cuantiosa suma de dinero de
moneda extranjera en un sofá en su casa
de campo
por su parte el presidente rama fosa
impugnó este lunes el reporte ante el
tribunal constitucional Mientras tanto
manifestantes a favor y en contra
protestaron en las afueras de la sede de
su partido y también en diferentes
puntos de Sudáfrica
sabemos que tenemos personas que quieren
colapsar este país son varios que están
afuera en particular los beneficiarios
de la captura Estatal
mis llamados de atención es a que Siri
rama fosa debe irse no podemos permitir
que se quede está desacreditando al
congreso nacional africano
pasamos ahora información del mundial de
Qatar 2022 hasta ahora Brasil está
jugando contra Corea y vence por goleada
así lo más probable es que sea la
selección que enfrente entonces a
Croacia en esa fase de cuartos de final
este último equipo avanzó después de
ganarle por penaltis a Japón en un
apretado partido que terminó uno a uno y
que tuvo que ir al tiempo complementario
y posteriormente a la de penales desde
toda nuestra enviada especial Natalia
Ruiz giraldo nos cuenta más detalles de
la jornada de hoy de este encuentro
no hubo sorpresa ni milagro japonés en
este partido entre los nipones y a
Croacia fue la experiencia finalmente de
los croatas la que salió a relucir en
este partido que terminó finalmente
definiéndose desde los tiros de punto
penal un partido bastante equilibrado
entre ambos equipos con Los japoneses
que abrieron por primera vez el marcador
en este mundial uno gol que vino sobre
el minuto 44 de madera sin embargo los
croatas respondieron ya sobre la hora de
juego con un cabezazo de perisic que
gonda no tuvo como atajar los dos
equipos subieron oportunidades cada uno
de poderse adelantar de poder conseguir
la victoria pero finalmente el partido
se fue ya a prolongaciones en la primera
parte fue mitoma quien tuvo la
posibilidad de marcar para Los japoneses
y en el segunda parte de esas
prolongaciones fue Mayer sin embargo ya
el partido se fue entonces a los o
penales y ahí pues fue la gran
desilusión de Los japoneses que cobraron
muy mal desde lo del tiro desde el punto
de tiro penal y también pues estuvo muy
bien al iva
guardameta croata quien atajó tres de
esos penales y de esta manera pues
acroacia se clasifica a los cuartos de
final por tercera vez Natalia Ruiz
reportándonos desde dua Qatar es todo
por el momento aquí en las noticias de
Francia 24 siga con nuestra programación
buenas tardes
[Música]